مرحبا مرحبا يا كريستيان من نون كيف
حالك سيد.  تشرفت Alper بلقائك
أيضًا ، شكرًا على قيادتك للسيارة ،
شكرًا للسماح لي بالسائق ، فأنت
تعلم ما لدينا من مغامرتنا التالية ، أتمنى أن
تكون قد سمعت عنا ، نعم ،
لقد راجعتكم قليلاً ولكني
أحب أن أحصل على مقدمة عنك
تفعل وكيف تقدمه نوعًا ما ، إنها
بوابة على الإنترنت حيث يمكن للناس استئجار
أي شيء يريدونه تقريبًا في الإمارات العربية المتحدة إذا
كنت ستذهب في رحلة إلى عُمان ،
فأنت بحاجة إلى GoPro لا ترغب في إنفاقه ،
تعرف زوجين  من آلاف الأحلام ،
يمكنك استئجارها لمدة أسبوع والاستمتاع
بها وإعادتها مرة أخرى ، حسنًا كشركة
ناشئة ، أعتقد أنك تعلم بوضوح أن
أحد أكبر التحديات التي تواجهك هو
رأس المال الصحيح وكيفية الاستفادة المثلى
من كل دولار  أن يكون لديك
المكان الذي ستركز فيه أكثر على
العلامة التجارية ، فهل ستكون 50/50 مثل أي
نصيحة ستكون رائعة ، أعتقد أن
أكبر اعتقاد خاطئ هو أن العلامة
التجارية والأداء هما نوع من الاستبعاد المتبادل
وهذا ليس صحيحًا ، يمكنك
التركيز على النمو الفائق  رشفة
التركيز على الأداء مع بناء علامة تجارية رائعة
لا تعتبر حملات للعلامة التجارية ،
غالبًا ما يسيء الناس تفسير ماهية العلامة التجارية
ويعتقدون أن العلامة التجارية تعتمد على
بناء حملة تضع اللوحات الإعلانية
في الشوارع والقيام
بمقاطع الفيديو الطويلة الرائعة هذه وإنفاق ثروة على
إنشاء محتوى هو  عدم وجود علامة
تجارية هو التأكد من أن كل
نقطة اتصال فردية وكل
تجربة فردية لديهم مع علامتك
التجارية تكون موحدة وتشكل
تجربة جيدة وجزءًا من
رحلة أكبر قمت بتنسيقها ، لذا فإن
الحصول على هذا التوحيد
هو ما تحتاجه  هل
أنت بحاجة لإثبات أن هذا نشاط تجاري قابل للاستمرار
وأن لديك عملاء وأن
الناس يأتون فعليًا عبر الإنترنت
وأنهم في الواقع يقومون بتحويلهم
بالفعل إلى تأجيرهم إذا كنت في
وضعك وكان لدي مبلغ محدود من
المال ما أفعله  هل كنت قد أنفقت كل
أموالي على تسويق الأداء أو على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ، سأنفق المال على
تطوير نوع من
الأداء الأساسي  الأشياء الاستراتيجية الرقمية للتسويق rmance
التي يمكنك تحمل تكلفتها
دون حرق الكثير من المال ،
وسأقوم ببناء حملة أداء ، ومن
ثم على جانب العلامة التجارية ، أود
التأكد من أن الرسائل أو
اللغة التي تستخدمها مختلفة نوعًا
ما ، فهي فريدة من نوعها.  إنها
لغة محلية ، إنها مألوفة ، لذا فإن أقصى قدر من
الكفاءة سيأتي من
القيام بحملات عبر الإنترنت ، والقيام بحملات
تعتمد على التحويل ، وهذا
سيكون نوعًا من شريان الحياة لكيفية
إثبات ما إذا كان هذا النموذج يمكن تحويله وما
إذا كان لديه أي نوع من الإمكانات ، لذا
هل ستستخدم  أتمنى التالي ، ثم فكر في
المنشور ، أعني أنه ليس لدي الكثير من الأشياء ،
لذا أعتقد أنني أستخدمها على كلا الطرفين ،
أقدر وقتك
أيضًا جيدًا لمقابلتك ، نعم ، لقد
كانت محادثة لطيفة وهذا ما أحبه يا رجل ،
نعم  ونأمل أن نراك قريبًا
وسأستخدم السؤال التالي ، حسنًا ، شكرًا
رائعًا ، يبدو رائعًا ،
اعتني جيدًا بثانية واحدة